se enfrentará a una barrera bastante
alta los demócratas tienen en este
momento la mayoría en el senado con
kamala harris que actúa como presidenta
del senado y pues ve a los demócratas el
voto duro 51 la mayoría simple sin
embargo lo que muchos analistas están
diciendo y varios senadores es que se va
a aplicar la acción del filibuster es
decir los republicanos que son minoría
van a obstruir el voto a poner un
bloqueo a pedir que se necesiten 60
votos y no una mayoría simple para que
estas dos proyectos de ley que fueron
aprobados en la cámara de representantes
pues sean aprobados en la cámara alta el
filibusterismo era una acción que usaban
antes los senadores donde obstruyen el
voto a través de discursos eternos
discursos muy largos para evitar
precisamente la votación pero en este
momento simplemente el filibuster pues
se hace a través de un correo así que un
correo de parte de algún republicano
obligaría a los 60 votos y no a la
mayoría simple